now having a beautiful day in the
villages we still have business here in
Florida one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
let the boys know what you want
this look was the hardest look I've done
of all season I'm wearing these big
silicone muscle arms and we're in
Orlando baby it is hot and then on top
of that we were literally working out
and maybe I've been for a long time
actually it felt longer than it should
have been right down that's wet we have
some of the best designers in the world
so I'm like if we're gonna ask Dominica
tour of this Emmy award-winning
designers make a lead it's hard we're
gonna go all the way we're going to make
it a muscle suit we're going to figure
out how to make it really really fun
maybe we're going to arm wrestle me and
I don't think they're not real muscles
there this is all for show I'm not gonna
arm wrestle anyone my hair inspiration
was mostly Grace Jones you know Grace
Jones has this famous picture of her
with like her hair is like going
straight up I have that hairstyle in the
90s I had a high top flat fade and I was
like this is my chance to like relive my
moment with my Afro Gloria really
innovated that in a really smart way it
wasn't too heavy but it also was like
solid like you couldn't actually put
your hands through it it was like built
around a cage my purse is an actual
dumbbell so it opens on both ends and I
am in eight inch stiletto platform um in
a muscle suit in the heat working out
this day was wild but I looked really
good
now take it one when I think aerobics I
think of Jesse Spano Saved by the Bell
there was a scene in an episode I know
maybe the Gen Z's you might not get this
one you're gonna have to go to YouTube
and look it up so I worked with Diego
and Ricky to come up with like this
whole Jesse Spano from Saved by the Bell
inspired look you see the flash Dancy
sweater that's cut and kind of off the
shoulder that says shanji custom across
the front you know a fun leotard really
hoppy 80s neon tights and the socks hold
up you can't have no 80s workout look
without the socks and then the hair wigs
and gray put together this gray Jesse
Spano inspired piece with the side
ponytail with a scrunchie because you
can have an 80s dude without the
scrunchie and to complete the look baby
you got to have the accessory so I had
this great workout bag that also said
changing right across the side I wanted
to be the drag Diva that worked out in
her humps and working out in pumps is
not the easiest thing I learned very
quickly
so we start from the top we've got this
Jane Fonda low back goldish blonde hair
that dirty like rustic blonde that was
really popular back then tease to Jesus
blown back with a nice feathered bang
makeup styled and ready very beautiful
soft because we're in the daylight we're
under these fluorescent lighting we take
it down we've got the crop top off to
the side because she's a sassy girl we
got the zebra suspenders the
multi-colors and greens and purples we
wanted to just have fun with a bee Camp
you know make it drag now listen I knew
this was a workout class and I wasn't
gonna wear a sneaker I had to wear some
kind of heel so I warm I don't hurt
yourselves the little daddies with my
snog warmers honey just enough yield to
make me feel like a lady but not kill
myself in this trouser size class and
then of course I have this giant water
bottle Honey by elephant logo on it you
always want to look petite and neat when
you're going to wear in class if you
carry the biggest bottle you can find
y'all were amazing
Vico is another one of my very eventual
daughters because Biko has such an
inspirational story overcoming tragedy
and Trauma for the show I wanted to give
him this opportunity to come out there
and celebrate all the parts of who he
was without fear so we wanted to have a
celebratory moment and give the Latin
flavor we've delivered that with the
Camila Cabello number baby
and it was feisty
Vito she's floating on the stage with
beautiful fuchsia color and I said okay
well I want to explode too I wanted to
feel like special guest hip-hop fish at
the BET Awards okay Diego and his team
put together this beautiful yellow look
for me monochromatic for one color both
even that wig so Gloria your teammate Ty
put together this beautiful little
finger wave piece we want to make a
drink so they added crystal diamond
accent into the hair to really make it
pop
the look you got this hat baby ostrich
brother dream that is just engulfing my
entire head that is a statement hat when
you walk into the hat like that maybe
everybody's gonna go
[Music]
in addition that we have the yellow
leotard that is sparkly and ready for
the stage going down to the custom boots
they're also made to match the same
fabric as the leotard so it's just
monochromatic
[Applause]
Mark was very determined if whatever we
were willing to throw at Mark Mark was
like let's do it you don't know where
the breastplate I'll do it you want me
to Nails I'll do it that is always a
great drag child to have you want
someone who's willing to go on the
journey and who trust a team so Mark
really like this like rock and roll Vibe
so we're like well let's make us into
some like really Fierce rocker chicks
and we want to tell the story of like a
rock Diva backstage in her robe doesn't
know if she can go on but then somehow
when you cross over the threshold Queen
backstage and on stage all of a sudden
you just transformed and you're ready to
go
I'm wearing the kitty cat wig looks like
a little short daytime judge wig with a
mohawk magnetically attached to it I
would run back staying they would slap
the mohawk on top of the kitty cat wig
and then I would run out and I believe
that Marx was fun pulled back with a
magnetic wig clipped onto it so it was a
real quick change and of course we have
complimentary outfits when he comes out
in this like nice of bold red
leatherette looking look I think it
really made him feel like a rocker
when I meet Jamie who's my drag daughter
and her daughter who's also my drug
daughter that does not make me a great
grandma just so we all are clear okay
I'm not a drag Mom I'm a drag mama
Jamie is a teacher in her everyday life
and in the Florida school system don't
say Gabriel was really and still is
having a huge effect Jamie has been such
an outspoken Ally not only for her
daughter but for students in her school
and the entire community so we had like
this graduation scene where she is so
empowered she's not going to let her
voice be suppressed We Do the song Katy
Perry's Roar who seemed to identify so
well with Jamie's story that she used to
be quiet and she used to bite her tongue
but she wasn't going to do that anymore
she is standing up for what's right
she's going to let her voice be heard
Diego and his team start out with a
graduation robe and then it delivers
that whole look with the hat and all
these pieces and then that comes off and
she's just in this powerful gown that is
just absolutely brilliant baby if you're
gonna have on a gown you want to have a
quaff wigs and Grace did the hair and
they really put together this amazing
like updo for her look and had it to go
easily with the cap so they had it
magneted into her so when she's dancing
it does not come off but at the end we
toss the hats and it's like the magnet
power of TV now also my Jamie she's like
she's like me we're Little Divas so she
wanted to feel a little taller on stage
and really give that whole statue with
drag queen look so we have her like a
platform boot now you can't see this
because she's in the Gown but baby her
stacked shoe is about this High under
that gown and she's working it and in
the number we wanted to make this feel
like a whole celebration of all the
family's efforts and you see them all
come out and celebrate and to hear the
pause from the audience the love and
support in this space where a lot of
times she doesn't get to hear that as
much it was really beautiful
[Applause]
I wish I'd have found this when I was
younger this is so me Mandy was my drag
daughter and then we incorporated her
wife into the mix Lori and it became a
really amazing dynamic because not only
was that story about Mandy's transition
in late life and how she's overcome so
many years of regret of waiting but then
also there was this incredible love
story of this couple being married for
50 years and them going through this
process I wanted to make it a fantasy
land I wanted to turn the stage in the
performance in the audience I wanted to
take him to this world of love my look
I'm the queen bee let's be honest I was
actually coming out as a non-binary
color to be at the time so I had all the
non-binary flag colors down the fur in
the front I had four arms you know
because I had to give drama and tan is
coming out of this nice swooped beehive
we've got the furry B body but still
sexy with black vinyl down to the nude
legs because I wanted to look like I was
flying or floating around favorite part
is on the back of this we've got these
beautiful pink crystal wings and a big
old Stinger honey you mess with this
queen bee you'll get stopped so we
decided to make Mandy this wonderful
caterpillar costume to the antennas to
this like beautiful purplish light lilac
hair soft and her as much as we could
and then made this like 3D textured full
caterpillar moment with little leg to
get out as it transitions on that
caterpillar tears off into a big
beautiful butterfly starting one phase
of life into another which is very Mandy
story well they were celebrating their
50th Anniversary small detail on the
wings was happy 50th anniversary on each
Wing it's really beautiful
[Applause]
I had lived trans earlier in my life and
I lived in so much fear so I decided to
backtrack my transition and it had been
a long time since I thought about it
meeting with Mandy and hearing her
stories and how she felt once she
decided just to face the fact she wanted
to transition and how free she felt
really made me think about it again I
had been living non-binary where I could
kind of live in the middle which was
where I was content and I realized in
that moment that my life couldn't really
be as glorious unless it was more than
content that I was happy I wanted to be
able to come out my own way this time
didn't realize how much it would change
me there's just something about all the
things that I teach to other people
about accepting yourself and removing
that anger and that displacement from
your heart and your mind I finally was
listening to and I guess I've just
gotten more comfortable with who I am
and it's like you know this is me
I hope people can learn something from
my experience and the way I came out and
hopefully be able to have and start
these conversations
the season was very powerful drag is the
ultimate in community building drag
gives you the ability to say I'm amazing
I can be loved and celebrated there is
an infinite amount of Love out here for
who you are today
[Applause]